also from what I hear around the UFC
water cooler the UFC did not want to
give Sean Strickland this title fight
from what I hear Izzy and his team is he
particularly called Dana was like give
me Sean Strickland I'll get rid of this
guy I will starch this guy because they
didn't want to give him the title shot
man we've heard but you know it's the
passport issue and all this I heard it
was the kind of the reservations from
the UFC going um we don't want this guy
in the message and the stuff that he
does also just from uh entertainment
standpoint he's a volume decision
fighter he's not a finisher so they
don't want that as their champion and
then sponsors there's a variety of
reasons the UFC brass doesn't want him
as the guy I think that's also why we
enjoy him and that's why you know we we
root for Sean Strickland we know he's
the guy who says F the man says things
you shouldn't say says off the cuff
stuff there's a lot of people that can
relate to that the breakdown is he get
done